[Music]
betty's next in oklahoma hi eddie how
are you
hey dave good uh how are you better than
i deserve how can we help
uh well first of all i want to say it's
a pleasure speaking to you
and ken bull and uh it's truly
pleasurable so thank you sir
so i was just offered um
a pretty exceptional position with
another company and i'm just kind of
torn between taking it and not
um it's a substantial pay increase and
and uh so i i just don't know whether i
should take it or not
cool what do you do now what do you make
and what's the new position and what
does it pay
uh so i work at a school local school
around me
and i make about 60k with that i retired
from the military recently and i make
about 60k with that as well
so i make about 120k right now
um the position offered to me
uh would start at 250k
and the only issue
that i see with it is that i'll be
traveling four to five days a week
so the biggest uh i guess
me and my wife were just trying to
figure out
do you have children we understand yes
so we have children
um i retired from the military because
i wanted to spend more time with my
family and children and uh
um now this presented itself and i'm
like man
that's i i mean it's hard to turn down
that much money
what age what age are your kids so
there's a gap four years old and 14
years old
so okay well
for 190 dollars a year you can have them
come with you a lot
yeah yeah uh you know you can put them
up you know they could have a great
adventure for a few years with you
uh part of the time and part of the time
they won't want to
uh and then the other question i would
have and then i'll let ken jump in
is is i wonder if there's a way to
structure the job
differently even if it paid slightly
less
where you had more time at home like
some way to do the job differently and
had
uh like 50 percent travel instead of 100
travel
so after six months um that is an option
okay how much how does it change after
six months
instead of instead of traveling uh four
to five days a week it'd be
more like two maybe three days a week
yeah so i'd still be traveling just not
as much maybe take a week off here and
there without traveling
okay so i have two questions then uh
first is dave's suggestion even doable
where you could take some of the kiddos
with you
on these trips absolutely okay
absolutely i think that's a i think i
think that's a game changer
uh and and then the six months you can
put up with just about anything for six
months and so my next question is
when it goes to two to three days a week
does that make your heart feel better as
opposed to four to five
and your wife's it does yes because i
mean that would allow me to
hit football games on mondays fridays
spend more time with the kids throughout
the week
as well as the weekend so yeah i think
it would well
i think i think that's changed i can
even hear it in you that's
changed it when you started focusing on
that i think when you called you were
dealing with head versus heart your
head's going
you'd be a fool to turn down that kind
of money but your heart's going
oh i don't know i don't want to be away
from my kids even two to three nights
isn't that what's really going on
exactly ken yeah exactly well so the
question becomes now that we've walked
through this
if it's six months of heart hurt
knowing though that you're doing so much
for the family with that additional
income and you're gonna get to travel
with some of the kiddos and have this
amazing one-on-one time with them
so that's gonna ease that heart hurts
not as bad and then after the six months
it gets even better
uh what's your head tell you now what's
your heart tell you after that
no i mean it feels better
well i think if your wife's on board
because i do believe in you know you
both need to be on the same page here
because they're still talking about two
to three nights a week but
if she's on board i think it's a
no-brainer here's the thing it's not
unusual
if you work in town to be out of touch
two nights a week just doing stuff with
out the kids with your friends you know
you're 100 correct
so you're not it's not like you know
it's not like you're there
24 7 anyway um and no one is
uh and so um and you know i think the
fun thing is just look at the six months
as an adventure with the kids
word has it if you're four years old
that the uh hotel pools are magical
it's actually true i don't know that
i've ever seen my kids more excited than
when we
tell pool yeah you get to go on a trip
with dad and there's a pool there
yeah that's true it's a good point well
yeah if you're four it's a big deal you
know and uh and get to travel and do
stuff and
you know spend some of the money to make
up the gap is the thing and turn it in
you know make it an extended weekend
that you pay off the expense account
uh if you're going to a cool location
you know we're empty nesters and the
idea originally was that sharon was
going to do a bunch of stuff with me but
she's figured out that traveling is not
um that it's like work when we're
working yeah
because when we're on travel and we're
working it's because we're
working sharon that's right so but yeah
she's like i mean
you know well then we need to go on
vacation there but when we're working
we're
okay so we had to have a different but
it didn't work out in other words but
the i think you could do that for six
months and then
two to three nights is really not a deal
killer if you're present when you're
home
i don't think you think you don't even
know you were your kids will remember
these trips with you
one-on-one more than anything else you
do with them yep like those date nights
exactly good stuff good question and
congratulations
what a nice what a nice kick and thank
you for your service you're a great
90 thousand dollars come up every day